[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de
l'europe qu'est l'europe voulons nous
alors l'europe aujourd'hui l'union
européenne rassemble 27 nations depuis
que la grande bretagne est parti avec le
break site en près de trois quarts de
siècle élargissement s'est fait sans
discontinuer il semble aujourd'hui
interrompue à l'est comme au sud le
contenu politique et économique s'est
approfondie à coups de traiter mais avec
des buts et sociales fiscales
environnementales et même
institutionnels et l'union européenne
n'est toujours pas une puissance en
mesure de rivaliser avec les états unis
et le continent émergents asiatiques sur
le plan idéologique le clivage entre
l'européisme fédéral et le souverainisme
des états nation rend aléatoire toute
identité européenne à même de forger un
véritable
sentiment d'adhésion européen et l'homme
y est devenue l'europe est un pur
reconnaissez cette maxime de paul valéry
on en est loin aujourd'hui
pour en parler je vous présente mes
invités je commencerai par vous jean
louis bourlanges vous êtes président de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
l'assemblée nationale
gérard araud vous êtes diplomate
écrivain vous avez été notamment
ambassadeur aux états unis et en israël
axe dieter loquace vous êtes ambassadeur
de la république fédérale d'allemagne en
france et celle inspector vous êtes
professeur universitaire essayiste ou
publier des livres
[Musique]
comment ne pas commencer par l'actualité
l'europe paraît spectatrice de la
résolution des crises notamment en
ukraine malgré le volontarisme politique
du président français
nous évoquerons plus avant dans
l'émission la question de la puissance
mais commençons par l'ukraine est ce
qu'il faut oui ou non
envisagées sont entrés dans l'union
européenne et au sein de l'otan ou alors
accepter
que ce pays n'entre pas dans l'otan pour
ménager la russie
jean louis bourlanges on n'a pas de
réponse ferme personne ne dit clairement
ce qu'il pense sur ce sujet oui c'est
extrêmement difficile de répondre à
votre question mais je crois j'avais
raison de la pose et il faut avoir le
courage d'y répondre je crois que dans
dans le dans un passé récent les
européens notamment les allemands et les
français ont marqué leur prudence et
leur réserve sur ces deux plans sur le
plan de l'adhésion à l'union européenne
et sur le plan de l'adhésion à l'otan
notamment à bucarest quand george
deubeuliou bush voulait absolument
élargir le temps à l'ukraine nous avons
temporiser sans doute n'avons nous pas
eu le courage de dire clairement les
choses moi je pense mais c'est une
opinion qui n'engage que moi il n'engage
pas le les pouvoirs publics français je
pense que l'ukraine a des relations si
proche avec la russie que c'est
effectivement ce serait effectivement
une provocation de la faire rentrer dans
le temps qui est quand même une alliance
qui est destinée qui est hostile à la
russie en revanche là où je ne suis
absolument pas d'accord avec le
président poutine comme là nous ne
sommes pas la coque le président poutine
c'est quand ils proposent des traités
deux traités qui aurait pour objet pour
effet de
d'intervenir de régenter à partir de
moscou le la politique de stationnement
des troupes au sol le temps et qui
aurait pour objet et pour effet de
permettre à moscou de dire qui doit être
membres de l'otan ou non je crois que
sur l'ukraine nous devons accepter que
l'ukraine ça veut dire marche c'est à
dire frontières et s'éteint c'est un
pays ambivalent à la fois occidentale et
est le berceau à certains égards de
l'identité russe nous devons le
construire sur en garantissant ses
frontières en garantissant la démocratie
et en lui permettant de se développer
économiquement en étroite relation avec
avec l'europe et c'est ça qu'il faut
obtenir pour simplifier monsieur
bourlanges c'est oui à l'union
européenne et non à l'otan s'est pas non
c'est sûr bac il faut vous ai failli
voir ça comme ça c'est un pays qui a
vocation moi qui a vocation à être un
trait d'union entre l'union européenne
et le et la russie qui a le droit au
modèle démocratique
qui est le nôtre qui a le droit à une
présence à une coopération extrêmement
active de l'union européenne mais qui
doit me semble-t-il compte tenu de sa
situation particulière sur le plan
géopolitique qui doit en même temps
rester dans une relation alors on parle
de la finlande je crois que le modèle
finlandais n'est pas tout à fait le bon
mais une une situation non pas de
neutralité et d'indépendance et de
non-alignement
garantie mais garantit le problème c'est
que il s'agit pas d'obtenir il s'agit
pas que monsieur poutine obtiennent de
nous un engagement de ne pas faire
rentrer l'ukraine dans le temps sans
qu'il y ait des contreparties
extrêmement précise les ukrainiens ont
droit à l'indépendance à la sécurité de
leurs frontières et c'est une situation
difficile parce que ils ont fait l'objet
d'une agression caractérisée par les
russes il ya quelques années les accords
de mines ont tracé la voie je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas on n'a pas été
peut-être les allemands les français pas
assez vigilant sur l'application de ces
accords je pense qu'il faut aller dans
cette direction et être à la fois très
ferme et est très très prudent il faut
voir que on vous a entendu les insultes
et des pays ça existe en l'ukraine et la
russie s'est pas c'est pas une histoire
ça peut pas être une histoire
d'hostilité
d'iter loquace un point historique vous
avez été à l'époque de la chute de
l'urss et de la réunification allemande
vous étiez diplomates et vous conseiller
le ministre allemand guen cher est ce
exact
ou est-ce faut que l'allemagne l'europe
a promis aux russes qui n'y auraient pas
d'élargissement de l'otan vers les pays
baltes également en ce qui concerne
l'ukraine la géorgie ce point de
l'histoire doit être clarifié cette
question à l'époque c'était pas sur
l'ordre du jour n'est ce pas oui en
effet lorsqu'on avait négocié d'un que
de la rhune l'unification allemande les
pays bas l'ukraine la biélorussie
faisait part de l'union soviétique qui
existaient à l'époque
c'était même chose pour la pole pacte de
varsovie donc à l'époque cette question
ne se posait pas du tout donc il n'y
avait pas de promesses n'est ce pas mais
elle a été évoqué oui ou non non elle
n'a pas été évoqué c'était
en avait discuté la question du statut
de l'herbe les chats de la rda
d'allemagne de l'est mais n'avait pas
discuté et caisses car il est promu
grèce par exemple c'est promis sur l'ex
rda qu'il n'y aurait pas de deux
conditions agressive de ce pays par
rapport à mesure pas de pas de
structures de l'otan sur le territoire
de l'allemagne de l'est très bien qu'est
ce que vous en pensez gérard obou sur
l'ukraine vous êtes non mais moi c'est
très clair de toute façon le crès ne
remplit pas les conditions les critères
pour être admise dans l'otan un c'est
l'otan a quand même des critères qui se
résume à une phrase très clair en
réalité l'ukraine l'otan ceva pour
donner de la sécurité à l'ukraine ça
serait de dire il faut prouver que
l'adhésion de l'ukraine alb améliore la
sécurité de ses membres c'est évident
que ce n'est pas le cas de surcroît il
ya un critère très clair qui dit qu' on
n'admet pas dans l'otan un pays qui a
des comptes des contentieux territoriaux
ce que demain si l'ukraine rendre dans
l'otan l'ukraine peut immédiatement
invoqué l'article 5 l'article delà de la
défense collective contre la russie donc
par définition l'ukraine ne peut pas
rentrer dans l'otan et je dirais que les
russes le savent parfaitement au moins
pour les dix ans voire les 15 ans qui
viennent en ce qui concerne l'union
européenne alors d'abord il ya de graves
problèmes même si on oublie la russie vu
la taille du pays vu l'état de son
économie vu ce que ça signifierait par
exemple pour la politique agricole
commune je vois mal ce serait quand même
difficile à digérer par l'union
européenne mais de surcroît lolë
l'ukraine dans l'union européenne ça
veut dire couper les relations
économiques avec la russie parce que
c'est adopter tout un ensemble de deux
critères de standards qui rendrait
l'économie ukrainienne en grande partie
1 compatible avec l'économie russe et
c'est pour cela que que d'ailleurs la
russie en 2014 a réagi très virulemment
après l' offre de nac d'un accord
d'association entre l'union européenne
et la russie qui aurait eu cette
conséquence donc je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le président bourlanges
s'il faut que l'ukraine soit en effet
une sorte disons moi je dirais plus
d'états tampon entre la russie et
l'union européenne
céline faye temps pour aller un tout
petit peu plus loin mais à partir de
l'ukraine est ce que finalement cet
élargissement sans fin trouve ses
limites à l'est comme au sud avec la
turquie alors je crois qu'il faut
essayer de dison de reprendre les choses
d'un peu plus haut c'est à dire la
question la vision des relations
internationales on a deux visions des
relations internationales qui
s'affrontent l'union européenne pendant
assez longtemps a défendu le droit
international et notamment le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes c'est
quand même un principe fondamental
d'autre part la russie depuis quelques
années semble vouloir se comporter un
peu plus comme un empire même si
évidemment avec des prétentions encore
relativement limitée
l'annexion la crimée en 2014 en témoigne
et donc on a une vision qui répondent
plutôt à la logique des sphères
d'influencé avec l'idée que les anciens
membres du pacte de varsovie doit
finalement rester dans la sphère
d'influencé et donc je pense que on a un
problème qui est décisif qui et comment
concilie ses différentes visions des
relations internationales alors
l'élargissement à l'est je pense n'est
pas complètement achevé on a un certain
nombre de pays qui sont encore dans
voilà dans les balcons comme on dit
qu'ils sont encore dans la processus de
demande d'adhésion mais si vous voulez
je pense qu'en tout cas il faut faire
très attention en effet je suis d'accord
avec cette question ukrainienne en
raison notamment des minorités
russophones qui sont effectivement très
nombreuses notamment effectivement le
long de la frontière et le cas de la
crimée et complexe puisqu'il ya eu un
référendum mais que ce référendum
évidemment n'a pas permis à tout le
monde de s'exprimer en réalité enfin la
discussion il revient quand même que
vous n'êtes pas globalement favorable à
l'entrée de l'ukraine dans l'otan
quitte à protéger ses frontières et à la
lui reconnaître une qualité
d'anti-européen ce que dit monsieur à
reuters juste les russes ne crois pas un
instant que nous que l'ukraine que nous
serions favorables à l'entrée de
l'ukraine dans l'otan donc il faut
savoir pourquoi les russes font aussi
tout ce tintamarre autour de la question
ukrainienne en réalité quels objectifs
poursuit monsieur poutine c'est ça qui
est est-ce qui poursuit un objectif de
reconstitution de de l'union soviétique
s qui poursuit un objectif visant à
empêcher une concurrence démocratique à
ses frontières une sorte de on sent bien
a eu une sorte de
d'unités idéologique avec tous ceux qui
sont hostiles à nos valeurs
démocratiques
les chinois même les nids turc même au
ban d'une certaine façon donc c'est il
faut savoir ce que veut monsieur poutine
c'est ça qu'a essayé je crois de de
comprendre le président de la république
française en dedans en discutant
de longues semaines avec le prince
moulay bien oui un mot là-dessus parce
qu'on va laisser poutine et la russie
qui nous concerne moins puisque notre
émission aller sur l'europe je vous
laisse je vois là mais vous aviez amour
vous aviez un mois
j'ai publié justement une biographie de
henry kissinger et or et qui suggère
pose cette question il dit le problème
face à un dirigeant comme poutine comme
air de ran comme si jean ping c'est de
savoir est ce que ce sont des dirigeants
qui veulent simplement améliorer leur
environnement géopolitique et on peut
leur parler ou est ce que ce sont des
dirigeants révolutionnaires
révisionnistes qui veulent bouleverser
l'ordre international et alors là dans
ce cas nous n'avons pas d'autre solution
que de résister et donc la question est
là que cherche évidemment la meilleure
poutine merci c'est tout à fait une mise
en cause dans l'ordre de sécurité
européenne cela notre vision n'est ce
pas parce que notre vision c'était
toujours
l'europe selon la charte paris pour une
europe nouvelle c'est à dire une europe
qui est basée sur le respect de la
souveraineté nationale
l'intérieur est royal navy la ville de
frontières et maintenant donc les
monnaies demande de monsieur poutine
c'est plutôt la vision du 19e siècle et
dans les discussions à moscou donc cette
idée d'un congrès de vienne des très
populaires donc pour nous c'est la
question est ce que nous voulons
vraiment une europe en scène deux mots
angleterre loquace est-ce que l' axe
franco-allemand à la même position
vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
tout à fait tout à fait vous confirmer
ça le jeu pas tout à fait pour le moment
donc la question de l'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne ou l'otan
ne se pose pas maintenant nous avons une
situation extrêmement dangereuse avec
des menaces militaires de la russie tout
à fait inacceptables contre les russes
contre l'ukraine et dans ce moment il
faut faire tout par la voie d'être
diplomatie pour faire en sorte qu'il ya
une désescalade c'est ça la tâche
prioritaire puis dans une deuxième étape
il faut at avoir avec la russie dial en
dialogue soit la question de l'ordre de
sécurité européen merci on va pouvoir en
parler alors revenons à notre union
européenne l'europe voulue par les pères
fondateurs est poursuivi par les grands
dirigeants européens a progressé à coups
de traiter pour la plupart géo politico
juridico administratif mais la question
reste toujours posée ou est ce peuple
européen où est cette opinion publique
européenne et grèves qu'est ce que vous
en pensez céline spector oui je suis
alors soit qu'il faut pas simplifier la
question du peuple européen parce que
tout dépend évidemment comment définit
le peuple si on veut le définir à partir
de l'idée de tradition commune d'une
langue commune peut-être même d'une
religion voire d'une ethnie commune
évidemment il n'ya pas de peuple
européen si la question c'est de savoir
si on peut faire quelque chose qui
ressemble à une fédération pluriethnique
et plurilingue alors là on commence à
réfléchir sérieusement et dans ce cas on
a une définition démocratique civique du
peuple qui n'a rien à voir avec sa
définition et nick qui consiste à dire
un peuple c'est une association
volontaire entre des individus qui sont
libres et égaux et qu'ils choisissent
pour leur utilité propre de se donner
des institutions communes et dans ce cas
on peut réfléchir sérieusement à la
question du peuple européen puisque en
effet les démos y les différents peuples
d'europe n'ont pas vocation à se
dissoudre bien sûr dans leurs structures
nationales dans leur identité nationale
mais ils ont à mes yeux vocation en
effet à former une entité supranationale
et à cette condition s'ils donnent leur
accord volontaire ce qui a été le cas
depuis 1900 la raison est très bien mais
il n'y a pas de ferveur européenne dans
aucun des pays de l'union européenne
alors la ferveur est quelque chose qui
se mesure du point de vue par exemple de
la fondation jean jaurès qui a produit
d'excellentes études d'intervention
récit les voir un peu une fondation ona
l'eurobaromètre on a des critères
objectifs pour mesurer l'opinion qui est
très variable en fonction des différents
peuples de l'union il se trouve que la
france est un des pays où en effet
l'adhésion enfin bon ça se mesure
difficilement d'ailleurs en fait
l'adhésion à l'union européenne et
peut-être plus faible que celle qu'on
connaît en italie ou que a fortiori en
roumanie où les pays bas et évidemment
mais il faut absolument se garder de
cette sorte d'impression vague selon
laquelle les peuples ne veulent pas de
l'union européenne mais si on n'a pas
parlé de volonté de l'union mais est ce
qu'il n'ya pas des facteurs affectif
d'adhésion qui permettrait code un élan
vers cette europe je crois d'abord qu'il
faut je vais citer un auteur que que si
beaucoup même spector qui est jean
jacques rousseau jean jacques rousseau
considéré qu' un contrat social avec un
corps politique dans un état aussi large
que la france c'était impossible il
rêvait de d'entités beaucoup plus
l'entité rêver c'était cantons suisses
il allait un peu jusqu'à là jusqu'à la
corse mais
sieyès en 89 quand il invente le pacte
social qui va être le pacte
de constitutionnel puis républicains ils
innovent complètement et ça marche on
peut dire ce qu'on veut mais là donc
tout ça c'est extrêmement variable c'est
extrêmement bon et là moi je crois que
ce qui se passe depuis quelques années
montre que même si nous avons beaucoup
de récriminations de difficultés et
surtout un sentiment profond que
l'europe ne délivre pas que l'europe ne
fait pas laisser ce à l'origine de
l'euroscepticisme à mon avis c'est qu'on
a le sentiment que l'europe c'est une
promesse qui ne se réalise pas
suffisamment mais en réalité regardez
les affaires du bataclan par exemple on
a eu une ferveur européenne de
solidarité avec les morts du bataclan
tente vraiment extrêmement est
extrêmement forte on a on a aux
dernières élections européennes
ça a été très frappant par rapport aux
précédentes pour la première fois on a
eu des enjeux qui ont été assez
largement perçu comme européens que ce
soit l'enjeu économique l'enjeu
migratoires l'enjeu terroristes et
remarquer que pour la première fois on a
inversé cette relation d'abstention on
avait une abstention croissante
scrutin après scrutin là on a eu une
participation
c'est encore tout ça ça se fabrique en
réalité quand on regarde la situation
géopolitique la chine une russie devenue
agressive une amérique centrale et de
servir il ya il ya une conscience qui je
crois est de plus en plus aigu du fait
que nous avons un destin commun alors ce
destin institutionnellement on n'a pas
du tout en fait élaborer suffisamment ce
que ce que ça pourrait être mais il ya
une attente profonde et à mon avis
l'euroscepticisme n'est beaucoup plus de
la de l'insatisfaction de du fait que
cette attente n'est pas récompensé que
d'une civic et à l'idée de faire des
choses ensemble
[Musique]
alors la référence à de gaulle n'est pas
inutile l'ambition initiale européenne
au sortir de la guerre pour légitime et
nécessaire qu'elle fut et demeure est-ce
qu'on sait pas mais pris par ignorance
sur la diversité des histoires des
cultures et des destins des peuples
européens et comme disait de gaulle par
entêtement idéologique
gérard araud mais moi pas du tout ajout
avouer que je suis alors pour peut-être
en tant que praticien je suis toujours
un peu étonné d'un côté vous avez tous
ces débats est ce qu'il ya un peuple
européen est ce que et cetera et cetera
lors c'est utile 1 et de l'autre vous
avez la machine européenne ça fonctionne
et pour moi en tant que praticien c'est
le plus important c'est à dire nous
avons développé depuis maintenant fort
longtemps nous avons développé des
politiques de coopération
vraiment très importante là que ce soit
d'un point de vue industriel que
l'agriculture la culture est vraiment
l'europe ça fonctionne et donc et c'est
ça qui compte et deuxièmement je crois
qu'il faut aussi éviter de chercher deux
des catégories de raisonner en catégorie
fédérale ou confédérale pas fédéral
l'union européenne c'est un objet qui
est non identifiés et qui le restera
demande identifier c'est une entreprise
qui n'a pas de pareil au monde avec des
vieux états qui ont décidé de se
rapprocher de travailler ensemble dans
certains domaines mais de ne pas
travailler ensemble d'ombré bella comme
je vous ai posé les bases elle l'art la
question c'est de savoir si quand on a
construit l'europe on a pris en
considération
les cultures les destins regarder ce qui
se passe avec la pologne la hongrie et
quelques manques on l'a fait on a pris
en compte toutes les institutions ont
été mises en octet mise en place de qui
permettent à la fois au pays de défendre
leurs intérêts les décisions sont prises
par qui à bruxelles 1 les décisions sont
prises par le conseil le conseil ce sont
les états qui coopèrent entre eux en
réalité l'union européenne ce sont des
états qui coopèrent entre eux avec
également l'intervention du parlement
donc je ne vois pas de problème
particulier qu'est ce que vous en pensez
en hésitant locale sans cela mais je
pense la même chose qu'eux gérard je
pense que ce sont les états qui agissent
mais avec du gouvernement qu'ils ont une
légitimité démocratique
exactement et il ya en plus donc le
parlement européen les institutions
européennes et il ya les règles commun
et ça à mon avis et c'est tout à fait
importante qu'il y ait là et qu'il ya
des règles communes et ça c'est cet
ensemble est institutionnel qui keane
qui facilite donc d'établir cette unité
d'action et enfin à mon avis donc c'est
une donc la faveur dont on a parlé ça
vient aussi avec l'efficacité la
capacité de l'union européenne de
résoudre les problèmes et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous semble que
cette c des secours de la source de la
route du renforcement de la souveraineté
européenne est tellement important c'est
à dire renforcer la capacité ils
reprennent d'agir de protéger
de défendre nos intérêts et nos valeurs
et ça et ça je pense qu'ils crient aussi
un espèce de légitimité
politique dont les yeux des populations
à votre avis céline spector plus de
fédéralisme ça permettrait de commander
deux traités par le haut ces questions
de
d'éruption culturelle de ce qu'on voit
par exemple apparaître avec la pologne
hongrie qui sont pas tout à fait
d'accord avec l'état de droit alors il
ya plusieurs plusieurs sujets si je veux
dire aujourd'hui l'union européenne en
effet n'est ni une confédération une
simple alliance d'état qui coopèrent ou
une simple organisation internationale
ni un état fédéral complet moi je
défends effectivement une fédéralisation
accrue parce qu'il ya si vous voulez une
asymétrie entre le fait que le marché
commun le marché intérieur est en
réalité doté d'un fonctionnement
fédératif avec à la commission notamment
en direction de la concurrence qui est
très active et d'autre part un ordre
politique qui lui restent largement
confédérative avec en effet le conseil
européen qui joue un rôle central même
si il faut pas oublier la commission
européenne qui a le monopole de
l'initiative législative est évidemment
le parlement devient un triangle
institutionnel
que tu n'aies le conseil des ministres
de l'union européenne fédérale que le
conseil aura absolument et donc si vous
voulez je pense qu'il faut malgré tout
avoir une réforme des institutions qui
puisse mettre à l'unisson le
fonctionnement fédéral du marché
intérieur avec ou si une banque centrale
qui nation fédéral et d'autre part un
ordre politique qui reste confédérati
fait qui empêche une régulation complète
de ce marché intérieur et notamment de
remédier aux effets pervers qu'il crée
en termes de dumping fiscal et de
dumping social vous partagez jean louis
bourlanges cette idée que plus de
fédéralisme ne réglerait les questions
vais vous répondre
gérard araud nous a en fait
illustre l à la fameuses caricatures de
caran d'ache sur l' affaire dreyfus par
le paon disant non ne parlait pas de
fédéralisme ou pas j'ai évidemment
aussitôt nous en avons parlé évidemment
et parce que le jeu je crois que c'est
dit spector a raison qui a fait des
analystes tout à fait remarquables dans
son dernier livre que je vous que je
vous recommande vraiment notamment sur
la les analyses extrêmement subtile sur
la souveraineté les différents types de
souveraineté et sur le fédéralisme moi
je crois si vous voulez que je crois
plusieurs choses je crois d'abord que
l'état est une fabrication de l'europe
que c'est une erreur de croire que les
quelques l'europe est tout simplement
une héritière de l'empiré romain en fait
l'europe historique c'est le nez du
fractionnement de l' empire romain entre
plusieurs royaumes qui ont qui ont eu
vocation à se constituer en état donc le
drame la tragédie de l'europe s'est calé
que l'état national est à la fois un
produit de l'europe est une promesse de
division et de déchirements qui aboutit
aux catastrophes du 20e siècle donc nous
avons inventé l'union européenne pour
surmonter cette contradiction est donc
pour faire naître entre les états et
c'est là on peut parler de pacte fédéral
impact comparable à celui que rops
définit comme un pacte entre les
individus il faut que les six pour que
les citoyens les individus soient libres
il faut qu'ils aient une relation
commune que c'est le léviathan chéops et
puis ça deviendra le contrat social chez
rousseau et mais il faut qu'ils aient
une langue commune pour qu'ils soient
levées hélas les états c'est quand même
une relation le à l'intérieur l'europe
c'est l'europe des états mais c'est
l'europe des états qui se soumettent à
une loi civile à une organisation
juridique un mode de fonctionnement qui
est extrêmement lent je vous fait appel
à ses fidèles à l'histoire mais les mets
jeu non mais je définis je termine
simplement par un mot je ne crois pas
que l'europe soit un état fédéral mais
je crois que c'est une fédération
d'états
création vous diriez que ne je ne sais
pas ce que c'est qu'une nation je sais
ce que c'est qu'un état je sais ce que
c'est que des citoyens j'ai énormément
de mal à me
je sais ce que c'est que la france mais
la nation il n'y a pas de ya la nation
il n'y a pas de nation qui soit pareil
l'une à l'autre les critères sont
entièrement différents l'état on sait ce
que c'est c'est un c'est une une
organisation juridique souveraine qui a
comme disent les juristes allemands la
compétence de la compétence ou comme
disait jean bodin qui à la la que la la
la la
souveraineté tels que elle est
absolument maîtresse de 2,2 de son
destin c'est tout ça ça existe et les
états se sont et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
une organisation européenne ils ont
délégué des compétences gérard araud le
disais dans certains domaines pas dans
d'autres et il s'agit de savoir si on
étend cette compétence et si on conforte
le système ce qu'on a fait avec un
parlement européen donc je crois que la
fédération des états c'est un modèle
fédéral mais c'est pas un état fédéral
dans la mesure où à la différence de ce
qu'était par exemple les états unis à
l'époque de lincoln et bien chaque étage
droit de partir vous assure is et gérard
araud donc je pense que la question
fédérale et je suis tout à fait d'accord
sur l'analyse de madame c'est quelque
chose c'est une question qu'il ne faut
surtout pas posée aujourd'hui
politiquement ses explosifs nous ne
pouvons pas au moment où les populations
sont en train d'exprimer par tous leur
je dirais leur mécontentement vis-à-vis
la manière dont l'union européenne
fonctionne on peut pas leur dire vous
n'êtes pas contents l'union européenne
on va vous offrir encore plus d'unions
européen cédait pas possible donc je
dirais que ce débat là pour le moment
nous avons la lune était sur l'été noir
voilà en faisons faisons de sorte que
l'union européenne que nous avons comme
le disait comme le disait monsieur
bourlanges et l'ambassadeur soit plus
efficace voilà alors monsieur
l'ambassadeur d'allemagne je voudrais
poser la question qui fâche parce que
elle est là et c'est le philosophe
allemand jürgen habermas parle d'une
culture politique européenne mais le
sentiment répandu aujourd'hui c'est
l'europe est devenue allemande citation
entre guillemets qui vient d'un
sociologue allemand ulrich beck est ce
que vous pensez qu'avec une allemagne
trop forte économiquement c'est un
problème pour l'europe et on le constate
même dans les paramètres économiques
si vous prenez par exemple différentiel
de la balance
commerciale vous êtes à plus de 100
milliards nous sommes à moins 70
milliards depuis 20 ans si vous prenez
les dettes publiques donc est-ce qu'une
allemagne
surproportionnée économiquement est un
problème pour l'europe est-ce que vous
acceptez ce sentiment là que nous tenons
bon oui mais je voudrais avoir sans abri
dans
cette vision pas d'une europe à le monde
mais une europe à une allemagne
européenne n'est ce pas c'est à dire une
allemagne qui est qui se bat la pop au
l'europe je pense était de toujours
notre vision est si vous lisez par
exemple de nouveau
contrat du de la coalition en allemagne
donc c'est très propre où européens et
ont fait des propositions très concrètes
pour rendre l'europe plus plus efficace
c'est à dire en ce s'exprime pour le
vote à majorité sur le home matière de
politique dans toutes les questions
politiques étrangère et la sécurité
pour des listes transnationales en ce
qui concerne les élections européennes
pour un droit d'initiative du parlement
européen c'est à dire pour nous donc le
renforcement dans tes de l'europe aussi
des institutions européennes c'était
d'une grande constante n'est ce pas de
la politique européenne de l'allemagne
depuis leur depuis des années des 50
donc ce que nous voulons pas c'est
vraiment pas une
europe allemande mais est-ce que
l'allègement des critères de maastricht
pendant cette période de co vide avec
mutualisation de la dette et tout ça est
ce que l'allemagne va accepter que ça
dure
avant le plan de relance avec l'habitude
les eaux sonede c'était une réponse à
une réponse extraordinaire à une
situation extraordinaire pour nous
c'était vraiment pas très important
parce que jusque-là donc la
mutualisation des dettes n'était pas
possible maintenant dans la crise on a
décidé donc maintenant donc il faut
vraiment aider nos voisins et on s'est
mis d'accord avec l'aco france sur cette
initiative visant à ce plan de relance
est maintenant je pense nous avons une
discussion sur la question comment
comment faire en sorte que cette cette
europe soit capable
de faire face au défi de la révolution
digitale numérique et aux changements
climatiques et pour cela il faut faire
des investissements
et ça c'est de cette discussion est
nécessaire maintenant dans quelles
mesures faut investir
desquels
ressources financières est ce que nous
avons besoin et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour le futur
un pacte de stabilité selon nous le
pakistan bt a fait ses preuves c'est
qu'ils
y compris à cause de sa flexibilité
mais il nous faut vraiment une
discussion sur la question comment
rendre le pacte de stabilité plus
transparent plus simple si vous voulez
rebours l'ange une une allemagne plus
solide économiquement il faut bien le
dire en fonction des critères
économiques
on le voit est ce que ça peut être un
problème mais bon je la france et pour
l'europe je crois que l'ambassade le
cash à traire appelé à rappeler la
formule de thomas span je veux une
allemagne européenne est pas une europe
allemande je crois que nous sommes tous
d'accord là dessus
moi il me semble que il faut aborder
cette question de façon très décomplexée
il est évident que l'allemagne gère
beaucoup mieux ses affaires que nous sur
le plan budgétaire sur le plan
commercial sur le plan industriel nous
avons beaucoup de progrès à faire nous
avons beaucoup de réformes à réaliser
nous avons la manière n'est pas parfaite
il ya des retards dans l'administration
publique dans lé mais il est évident que
milla a une une
supériorité de la gestion économique
d'allemagne une supériorité la puissance
allemande par rapport à nous cela dit je
crois que nous avons de grands atouts et
surtout que l'europe reste très
profondément marqué c'est pas du tout
une europe à larmor l'allemagne l'europe
et dresse très profondément marqué par
les idées françaises nous avons été
porteur depuis trente ans et ça se ça se
manifeste maintenant de plusieurs choses
nous avons été porteur de l'exigence
d'un complément budgétaire par rapport à
louer mais je vous ai interrogé sur la
supériorité économique de l'année
c'est un constat oui mais la nasa où est
ce que ça peut poser un problème bien
sûr qu'il vaut mieux qu'on soit il vaut
mieux qu'on soit meilleur assaillent
venir on le fait on cherche ça mais on
le fait
laissez-moi exprimer les choses sur le
plan sur le plan économique nous avons
toujours dit que l'union monétaire
devait être complétée par une union
économique et budgétaire aujourd'hui on
le reconnaît sur le plan énergétique
nous avons toujours dit qu'on ne
pourrait pas faire on ne pourrait pas
réaliser une gestion écologique
de dunes une gestion du défi climatique
de façon satisfaisante sans faire appel
au nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est s'est
reconnue sur le plan international nous
avons toujours considéré que l'europe
c'était très bien comme machine à faire
la paix comme machine à nous en tant les
uns les autres comme machine à faire des
normes mais que nous avions un défis
géopolitiques qu'on appelle en france 20
soit un petit peu excessive l'europe
puissance disons on va en parler dans le
détail après et là là encore nous sommes
aujourd'hui assez profondément reconnu
donc je crois qu'en réalité le tandem
reste assez profondément équilibré
l'europe n'est évidemment si l'allemagne
n'avait pas adhéré vraiment madame
merkel au moment du plan en fait les
rachats n'avait pas adhéré entendus sur
un souci d
europe à le monde qu'est ce que vous en
pensez gérard araud ulrich beck le dit
c'est pas c'est pas un contempteur de la
politique franco allemande l'union
européenne d'une certaine manière nous
avons transféré nono contentieux des
champs de bataille dans les corridors de
bruxelles c'est ça l'union européenne
c'est un mécanisme de dos au cid pour
faire la paix entre nous pour régler nos
problèmes entre nous c'est dans les
corridors de bruxelles ça se règle sur
la base de quoi des rapports de force
toute solution prises à bruxelles est
plus proche de la position de
l'allemagne que la position du portugal
c'est comme ça c'est des rapports de
force qui sont là et que comme on est
des européens on essaie de les
dissimuler parce que on n'aime pas ça
donc on utilise on utilise sentir bien
il s'en tire bien mais voilà une fois
que vous avez dit ça il est évident que
tu fais du break site qui nous le
président pour l'europe c'est un
désastre parce que ça bouleverse les
rapports de force à où il y avait un
triangle britannique france allemagne
maintenant il n'y a plus que france et
allemagne et donc le rapport de forces
est favorable à l'allemagne mais c'est à
cause des vertus allemande et des est
dépêchée français et donc il nous
revient à nous de rétablir le rapport de
force en réformant notre économie alors
c'est l'inspecteur je prends un exemple
j'ai pris l'économie où on voit très
nettement que l'économie allemande se
porte beaucoup mieux que l'économie
française mais dans l'art par exemple si
vous prenez les trois plus grands
plasticiens aujourd'hui en scène qui
faire richter et baselitz ils sont
allemands c'est à dire que vous avez
aussi une influence allemande culturel
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
influence allemande est dominante alors
les
scènes trait pour trait pour le spectre
est large
oui certes mais bon moi mon vrai
problème c'est finalement plutôt jusque
là vraie question qu'on a posé c'est la
question de l'euro par exemple est-ce
que l'euro a profité de manière
disproportionnée à l'allemagne est-ce
que l'euro entraîné la
désindustrialisation partielle de la
france et d'italie ça c'est une vraie
question parce que beaucoup du
mécontentement en effet qui existe dans
l'union européenne tient notamment à la
vulnérabilité à sion de populations qui
sont liées à cette désindustrialisation
donc ça c'est une vraie question les
économistes ont travaillé là dessus et
apparemment il se trouve qu'en les faits
l'allemagne a plus profité de l'euro
alors elle a d'autres vertus qui lui ont
permis par ailleurs de bien prospéré
mais c'est une c'est un vrai problème et
ça je pense qu'il faut en prendre la
mesure lorsqu'on réfléchit à la réforme
du pacte de stabilité et de croissance à
laquelle je suis pour ma part favorable
c'est à dire je ne suis pas pour lever
tous les doutes les contraintes parce
que dès qu'on a une monnaie unique il
faut un gouvernement de la monnaie
unique il faut d'ailleurs un
gouvernement de la zone euro mais si
vous voulez l'idée que voilà l'allemagne
pourrait effectivement dominé
économiquement
sans qu'il y ait de contrepartie c'est
très dangereux d'autant que l'europe a
aussi été fondée donc sur l'idée de paix
perpétuelle vous l'avez rappelé mais
aussi sur l'idée d'une interdépendance
des économies et des besoins qui
permettait de créer une société civile
européenne et ça c'est une idée que
montesquieu dans l'esprit des lois par
exemple promu l'idée qui est derrière
cette belle idée quand même c'est qu'on
va arrêter le mercantilisme ou le
colbertisme c'est à dire finalement
chaque état essaie d'avoir une balance
commerce al telle qu elle finalement
écrase ses voisins donc l'idée d'origine
c'est le doux commerce de montesquieu
par exemple c'est l'idée que en fait
grâce aux transactions économiques on va
remplacer la guerre par le commerce la
négociation remplace la prédation et ça
suppose des états qui sont relativement
fort c'est-à-dire qu'on suppose que les
voisins vont être les débouchés
effectivement de notre économie kelly
classe écrasé il faut et voilà je crois
que l'allemagne a en effet compris et ça
a été un revirement spectaculaire
à l'origine du plan de relance que en
effet si ses voisins était trop affaibli
et bien même son économie très prospère
aurait des problèmes chez moi de
demander une précision monsieur
l'ambassadeur
est ce que c'est un revirement la
mutualisation de la dette qui a eu
pendant le coc vide ou c'est juste une
mesure ponctuelle est ce que l'allemagne
prend conscience aujourd'hui qu' il faut
trouver un équilibre territorial entre
les différents pays d'europe nous sommes
donc le plan de relance comme j'ai déjà
dit c'est une c'est une réponse
nécessaire à une situation
extraordinaire
et la question pour le futur et comme
j'ai déjà dit c'est vraiment la question
des investissements qui sont nécessaires
pour rendre l'europe plus efficace sur
le plan digital mais aussi pour lutter
d'une manière efficace le changement
climatique et pour cela il nous faut des
investissements énormes oui mais vous
qu'on sait ça et ça se sent que
l'ambassadeur vous comprenez qu avec une
allemagne qui a un excédent commercial
depuis 20 ans de 200 milliards et une
france qui a entre moins 70 et 80
milliards de déficit les il n'y a pas
les mêmes moyens d'investissement oui
c'est aussi une tâche pour l'union
européenne tout à fait mais c'est cette
discussion dont nous avons besoin
maintenant sur le futur dans un modèle
européen de croissance et s'étend à mon
avis aussi un grand sujet prend la
présidence française du conseil et nous
allons donc contribuer à cette
discussion du meilleur tout à fait tout
à fait constructive mais pour le moment
je pense il n'y a pas encore une une
réponse claire soit du côté français
soit du côté à aman à 7,7 à cette
question mais dans ce contexte il faut
comme j'ai déjà dit aussi discuter donc
le pacte de stabilité
nous attendons maintenant à la
proposition de la commission donc soit
le refonder le pacte de stabilité et
puis dans ce sera la base pour les
discussions entre les états et non
[Musique]
alors il ya une expression qui fait
florès en france c'est l'europe
puissance les français sont favorables à
cette europe puissance il ne semble pas
que les autres pays soient dans la même
logique même si l'allemagne évolué est
ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une évolution
stratégique de l'europe vers cette
notion de puissance monsieur blanche je
crois pas que ce soit un mot très
heureux leur puissance parce que ça ça
renvoie comme le disait l'ambassadeur
d'allemagne ça renvoie au 19e siècle le
concert des puissances etc c'est une
vision quand même
assez d'apt et des choses en revanche ce
qui est clair c'est que l'europe doit
être puissante et respectée et que
l'europe l'union européenne s'inscrit
comme le disait monsieur arrow dans un
rapport de force extrêmement est
extrêmement exigeant extrêmement dur
nous avons pensé à tort après la guerre
où nous avons construit l'europe dans
une bulle une bulle d'ailleurs garanti
par les états unis d'amérique et il
suffisait d'être de s'entendre bien les
uns les autres d'être exemplaire de
pratique et bien les droits de l'homme
de le respecter les libertés
fondamentales et tout se passerait bien
en réalité nous vivions sous protection
américaine or depuis pratiquement depuis
la chute de l'empiré soviétique
nous sommes dans une situation
différente et jusqu'à présent nous n'y
avons pas fait face c'est à dire que et
nous commençons de comprendre qu'il faut
y faire face sire que nous sommes quand
même on a vu avec trump que l'amérique
nous protéger ou de nous protéger pas on
a vu avec bye donne que bas peut-être
qu'ils s'intéresseraient plus à la chine
qu'à la russie lors poutine a ramené les
américains en europe si je puis dire on
voit qu'on est confrontés nous
directement à à l'islamisme
l'afghanistan c'était une menace la
chute de 2 des états unis eau en
afghanistan c'est une menace directe
pour nous en termes de drogue en termes
d'immigration
en terme de terrorisme donc nous ne
pouvons plus nous abstraire d'une
réalité fondé sur la puissance est là
c'est une conversion intellectuelle que
dont les français sont très conscients
et donc voudrions que l'ensemble de nos
partenaires à commencer par les
allemands soit aussi conscients que nous
du fait qu' il s'agit pas simplement de
faire la paix c'est très bien la paix
entre nous c'est fait c'est formidable
comme à tout comme comme acquis mais il
s'agit maintenant l'union fait la force
il s'agit maintenant d'être ensemble
face à des chinois qui ont quand même
une évolution inquiétante face à des
russes qui ont l'évolution que vous
savez face à un monde islamique qui est
très dangereux et à côté d'eux des états
ou des dames d'une amérique qui est plus
incertaine donc nous ne pouvons pas
éviter les enjeux géopolitiques de la
puce en or si alors gérard araud est ce
que vous pourriez précisé vous qui avez
été ambassadeur aux états unis
ambassadeur de france aux états unis
comment cette défense européenne peut
s'autonomiser si jamais le fait de la
puissance américaine avec l'eau de
l'otan qui est là comment vous voyez est
sain que nos partenaires ne veulent pas
de défense européenne c'est ça le point
le problème fondamental pour des raisons
multiples nous le débat sur la défense
européenne est un débat franco français
en grande partie parce que nos
partenaires considèrent que leur horizon
et l'horizon euro-atlantique et donc
pour eux la sécurité elle ne peut se
concevoir sans les états unis je suis
d'accord avec le président bourlanges
les européens sont en déni sur le fait
que les américains sont en train de
quitter l'europe sur la pointe des pieds
mais tant qu'ils sont en déni tous les
pays européens que ce soit l'allemagne
et le rouler ou les autres préfèrent
répondre ont inévitablement au temps au
temps au temps et vous êtes sûr que les
états unis veulent se défaire de leurs
liens en europe que les états unis c'est
pas se défaire des liens mais les états
unis sont en train de faire un pivot
central vers un pivot vert vers l'asie
vers la chine on l'a bien vous savez par
exemple ça commençait sous obama l'afer
qui négocient sur le l'ukraine la france
et l'allemagne mais est-ce que vous
pensez que les états unis ont laissé la
france l allemagne prendre cette
négociation en main par amour pour la
france et l'allemagne non parce que les
états unis ne voulait pas s'impliquer
que les états unis les états unis
calmement réussi à ne pas s'impliquer
dans la crise craignant une crise
majeure que la crise syrienne je peux
vous expliquer personnellement que sur
la libye c'est nous qui les avons
poussés il ne voulait pas venir les
états unis et ça a été déclaré
d'ailleurs par le président byden au
moment de la débâcle de kaboul il a fait
un discours en disant nous ne voulons
intervenir que pour les intérêts vitaux
des états unis est donc pour le moment
les autres européens ne le pense pas et
donc pour les autres européens c'est
autant autant vous allez pendant vingt
ans j'ai essayé de construire la défense
européenne je peux vous dire que les
français nous étions seuls et que tout
ce que nous avons fait commencez vous
avez raison mais ça évolue oui est-ce
que ça évolue côté allemand monsieur
l'ambassadeur je pense que vit donc si
vous lisez par exemple de nouveau le
programme gouvernemental du nouveau
gouvernement donc c'est la grand
leitmotiv c'est la souveraineté
stratégique de l'europe et ça veut dire
aussi un engagement très fort pour
l'europe de la défense je pense qu'on a
vraiment fait du du progrès on a crié en
fonds européen de défense on a établi la
coopération permanente structuré et il
ad'autres maintenant pendant la
présidence française travaille sur une
boussole stratégique en grand document
cadre qui donne une orientation
stratégique pour l'europe y compris sur
le plan des capacités mais sur l'otan
vous n'êtes pas tout à fait d'accord
avec la wanna tout à fait d'accord parce
que l'autre concerne il faut il faut
faire l'europe de la défense c'est tout
et c'est la raison pour laquelle avec la
france nous sommes engagés pour les
grands projets les victoires monsieur
l'ambassadeur est ce qu'il ya une
différence entre la france et
l'allemagne les uns utilise le terme de
souveraineté stratégiques et les autres
autonomie stratégique
est-ce que c'est pas là il ya une petite
différence c'est que vous voulez
maintenir le lien avec les états unis je
pense la france veut aussi maintenir le
lien avec aisance à ce que vous dites
est allé je laissais leur répondre a
pris la parole mais les vanités
autonomie c'est dans l'autre sens où il
nous aide nous avons parlé de
souveraineté est également parler
d'autonomie et maintenant les allemands
parlent de souveraineté oui mais les
faits leur répondais gic oui mais à mon
avis la substance est là même si on
parle de la souveraineté européenne à la
sauvette et stratégique de l'europe il
faut vraiment faire en sorte que
l'europe soit capable d'agir y compris
sur le plan de la défense mais en ce qui
concerne la défense collective a par
exemple dans un grand conflit avec la
russie je pense qu'il serait réaliste
d'assumer dans ceux ci ne serait pas
possible sans les états unis il y a
toujours l'aspect nucléaire non merci
donc et de ce point de là je pense est
tout à fait réaliste de dire l'otan est
tout à fait nécessaire et par ailleurs
c'est la position du gouvernement
français alors écoutez on va terminer
cette émission puisque il faut bien là
ponctuée par une question vous
préoccuper beaucoup céline spector est
ce que vous pensez sincèrement qu'on
peut défaire
la france en fédérant l'europe ou vice
et versa vous savez c'est la critique
des anti européens et je la pose parce
que je vais vous dire en france nous
avons entre l'extrême droite et
l'extrême gauche une masse non
négligeable qui est anti européenne et
donc je pense que si on veut convaincre
je vous laisse la parole à ce sujet
alors il s'agit en aucun cas de défaire
la france tout d'abord historiquement en
fait les souverainetés nationales se
sont renforcés grâce à la mise en commun
d'un certain nombre de compétences ils
n'ont pas renoncé à leur souveraineté
ils ont simplement transférer les
compétences qui étaient plus efficaces
lorsqu'elles étaient exercées ensemble
et donc ils ont créé une souveraineté
qui ne pouvaient s'exercer qu en commun
et c'est ça qui est fondamental c'est
pas le fait d'avoir des faits des
souverainetés ça a été démontré en fait
les états nations se sont renforcés il
ya une ruse de la souveraineté une
dialectique de la souveraineté qui fait
qu'en réalité ils n'ont pas perdu en
utilisant ce nouveau contrat social
européen
donc je ne suis pas du tout persuadé que
les identités nationales vont se
dissoudre que les souverainetés
nationales vont se perdre simplement
elles vont être plus efficace on peut
l'espérer en tout cas si elle arrive à
exercer en commun un certain nombre de
prérogatives notamment dans le domaine
énergétique dans le domaine écologique
et dans le domaine de la défense écoutez
vous remercie cette émission se termine
on va vous proposer une bibliographie
écoutez je un livre d'acquis lino morel
l'opium des élites c'est un opus on peut
pas dire anti européens mais qui est
contre l'europe fédérale qui met en
cause une partie politique notamment la
gauche française qui a gouverné ces
derniers temps disant qu'elle était
responsable du libéralisme c'est un
parti pris mais dans une émission il
faut donner un livre anti libérale c'est
un livre anti libérale vous voulez vous
l'avez précisé mais l'auteur se réclame
de l'antilibéralisme pas moi baho sedin
spector nos demos est ce que vous pouvez
dire deux mots pourquoi vous l'avez
appelé node est moche avec un point
d'interrogation
demos étant le peuple
kratos pouvoir
alors en fait dans les yeux pn stadistes
dans les études européennes la théorie
d'une eau des mosses la thèse d'une eau
des mof c'est une thèse répertoriés
consistant à dire parce qu'il n'ya pas
de peuple européen et qu'il n'y en aura
jamais il ne peut pas y avoir de
démocratie européenne il n'y en aura
jamais donc tout le livre est centrée
sur la déconstruction de ce qui
m'apparaît comme un sophisme et donc
j'essaye de montrer qu'en fait on peut
tout à fait concevoir une démocratie
européenne
alors jean louis bourlanges vous êtes un
européen convaincu
je dirais même convaincant puisque vous
porter le drapeau européen
vous avez publié dans le temps un livre
qui s'appelle le diable est-il européen
est ce que vous pensez qu'à travers
cette expression on dit souvent le
diable est dans les détails on a voulu
trouver un bouc-émissaire avec l'europe
oui on a voulu bien sûr on a on a
toujours cherché à attribuer à l'europe
des
délais responsabilité de ce qui n'allait
pas moi je vous le dis ce que je pense
c'est que c'est pas plus ou moins
d'europe mais c'est que l'europe de
l'union européenne devrait être avoir
les moyens les moyens juridiques les
moyens budgétaires de faire plus qu elle
le fait je pense que l'europe c'est une
mise en commun des compétences et ce qui
déçoit c'est que ces compétences ne sont
pas exercer de façon pleinement efficace
on mais c'est toujours l'europe c'est
toujours trop peu et trop tard
c'est ça le problème il faudrait qu'elle
soit plus rapide plus dégourdis plus
plus agile comme on dit qu'elles aient
les moyens d'agir et ça c'est une
question pratique comme le disait gérard
ans où c'est une question pratique c'est
pas simplement une question théorique il
faut réfléchir à améliorer le système
pour qu'on puisse véritablement mettre
un peu moins de 6 mois à prendre une
décision et un peu moins de trois ans à
faire une directive et à se mettre en
ordre de marche pas tu quatre mois après
le début d'une crise c'est ça c'est il
faut il faut qu'on nous qu'on comprenne
la cape qu'on trouve les moyens de se
développer c'est là où est le problème
merci alors gérard araud vous avez fait
la biographie d'un européen si je puis
dire henry kissinger qui a été
secrétaire d'état le diplomate du siècle
d'un très beau livre d'air mais en même
temps vous l'eau vous admirez beaucoup
ce personnage vous n'hésitez pas à le
critiquer voudrais vous poser une
question si on prenait la diplomatie
française qui lui correspond talleyrand
à quel exemple on peut comparer à quel
exemple peut le gérard araud non pas du
tout le monde vous savez le il admire et
particulièrement le général de gaulle à
il était vraiment plein d'admiration
pour le général de gaulle il a écrit sur
le général de gaulle donc je crois il
s'inscrit quand même dans la vision du
monde du général de gaulle c'est à dire
d'un monde de carnivores et je crois que
c'est cela qu'il est d'actualité parce
que nous sommes nous voyons bien leur
tour du monde carnivores et comme disait
le président bourlanges l'union
européenne jusqu'à maintenant est un peu
herbivores et donc dans ce monde de
carnivores et bien nous devons nous
devons nous muscles et nous devons être
capables de faire face aux grands
carnivores qui nous entoure et s'éteint
c'est aussi lui qui a critiqué l'europe
en 10 ans quel numéro oui c'était dans
les années 60 donc maintenant je suis
sûr qu'il aurait pas ce problème parce
qu'il aurait trois numéros faut
au moins trois noms vous pensez qu'il a
évolué c'est oui là l'union européenne a
évolué naturellement voilà merci
madame merci messieurs on va terminer
cette émission avec cette citation
d'emmanuel macron qui montre un peu si
vous voulez la dimension pas
contradictoire mais j'allais dire en
même temps dieu de notre émission je
crois dans la souveraineté les
souverainetés nationales qui sont les
nôtres mais je crois dans la
souveraineté européenne
[Musique]